that was good exercise for a moment that
was that was pretty good now so what we
want to do that was a big thank you to
all of the developers who've done so
much for us but we have a another
specific thank you we'd like to do and
that is a Randy Bryant and if we could
invite Randy Bryan who is the Dean of
computer science department at Carnegie
Mellon on stage could you
thank you by the way I'm very gratified
to see you and your role as software
rockstar as one of our alumni yes indeed
so you guys have had a project going on
at CMU for quite a few years it's been
really influential in educating people
people let's get some breath back you
haven't been playing a lot of hockey
yeah no I haven't but then you just had
to stand there but anyway you guys the
school computer science the Alice
project and of course the leader of the
LS project randy pausch we've done a
phenomenal job teaching kids programming
and teaching it through java and getting
the visually engaging excited and so
thank you very much thank you thank you
so Randy Pausch had a vision of of
getting young people hooked on
programming by having them tell stories
and create games using a input
programming notation based on visual
graphics and he deployed that with the
program Alice to which is widely
available and in fact is downloaded
about a thousand times a day from the
servers at Carnegie Mellon and now the
new version ls3 is just coming out and
it's one of its roles is to help people
learn java programming by having a
transition where they can go from this
graphic input to writing code using
NetBeans and it's being demoed here at
javaone in the pavilion I recommend you
come take a look by the java the ellis
team we've also had a lot of support
from Electronic Arts has donated the
rights to the sims characters which are
very compelling a course and sun which
has given us quite a bit of technical
support randy pausch as you know
I became famous for a lecture he gave at
Carnegie Mellon in the fall of two
thousand seven part which was that he
had terminal cancer and unfortunately he
died last July but Alice continues as
his legacy and we're very pleased for
the ability for sun and for java
developers to make use of it yeah and so
so Randy wasn't just a professor at
Carnegie Mellon he was also a student
there he had a long association with the
place and I actually got to interact
them because we were grad students at
the same time and he was pretty amazing
guy must have been the waters or not or
the I mean Pittsburgh day don't drink
the water but bars are great right very
good thank you thank you thank you Scott
oh thank you thank you
so we'll have a minor dip in the IQ up
here on stage here is those to leave the
stage vote